je ressens tellement courageuse et plus
des touches g quelle personne à tout
seul sur mes yeux elle n a éprouvé la
première les effets du lsd
elle a eu chaud elle a eu froid elle a
senti sa nuque s'alourdir
ses joues se durcir elle se plaignait
puis elle a commencé à voir le tapis
grouiller de serpent au mur se déformer
les visages se rétrécir autour d'elle
jean ensuite à vue le plafond couler
comme si le plafond n'était pas pris
puis il s'est cru au bord de la mer
c'était merveilleux puis c'était la
tempête
[Applaudissements]
ellen croit voir bouger un poisson
d'argent
[Applaudissements]
voilà voilà
le lsd les rapprochent ils vos délires
et ensemble jusqu'à la fin ils sont
emportés par la drogue absolument
annihilée par elle alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]